all right well let's get started
today and indeed today and tomorrow I'm
gonna talk about raft both because I
hope it'll be helpful you for you in
implanting though the labs and also
because you know it's just a case study
in the details of how to get state
machine replication correct so we have
introduction to the problem you may have
noticed a pattern in fault-tolerant
systems that we've looked at so far
one is that MapReduce replicates
computation but the replication is
controlled the whole computation is
controlled by a single master another
example I'd like to draw your attention
to is that GFS replicates data right as
this primary backup scheme for
replicating the actual contents of files
but it relies on a single master to
choose who the primary is for every
piece of data another example vmware ft
replicates computational write on a
primary virtual machine and a backup
virtual machine but in order to figure
out what to do next if one of them seems
to a fail it relies on a single test and
set server to help the choose to help it
ensure that exactly one of the primary
of the backup takes over if there's some
kind of failure so in all three of these
cases sure there was a replication
system but sort of tucked away in a
corner in the replication system there
was some scheme where a single entity
was required to make a critical decision
about who the primary was in the cases
we care about so a very nice thing about
having a single entity decide who's
gonna be the primary is that it can't
disagree with itself right there's only
one of it makes some decision that's the
decision it made but the bad thing about
having a single entity decide like who
the primary is is that it itself as a
single point of failure and so you can
view these systems that we've looked at
it sort of pushing the real heart of the
fault tolerance
Machinery into a little corner that is
the single entity that decides who's
going to be the primary if there's a
failure now this whole thing is about
how to avoid split brain the reason why
we have to have have to be extremely
careful about making the decision about
who should be the primary if there's a
failure is that otherwise we risks split
brain and just make this point super
clear I'm gonna just remind you what the
problem is and why it's a serious
problem so supposing for example where
we want to build ourselves a replicated
test and set server that is we're
worried about the fact that vmware ft
relies on this test and set server to
choose who the primary is so let's build
a replicated testing set server i'm
gonna do this it's gonna be broken it's
just an illustration for why why it's
difficult to get this but brain problem
correctly so you know we're gonna
imagine we have a network and maybe two
servers which are supposed to be
replicas of our test and set service
connected and you know maybe two clients
they need to know who's the primary
right now or actually maybe these
clients in this case are the primary in
the back up in vmware ft so if it's a
test and set service then you know both
these databases mostly servers start out
with their state that is the state of
this test flight back in zero and the
one operation their clients can send is
the test and set operation which is
supposed to set the flag of the
replicated service to one so i should
set both copies and then return the old
value so it's essentially acts as a kind
of simplified lock server okay so the
problem situation the lowly worried
about split-brain arises when a client
can talk to one of the servers but can't
talk to the other so we're imagining
either that when clients send a request
they send it to both I'm just gonna
assume that now and almost doesn't
matter so let's assume that the protocol
is that the clients supposed to send
ordinarily any request to both servers
and somehow we you know we need
think through what the clients should do
if one of the server's doesn't respond
right or what the system should do if
one of the server seems to gotten
responsive so let's imagine now the
client one can contact server one but
not server two how should the system
react one possibility is for is that we
think well you know gosh we certainly
don't want to just talk to client to
server one because that would leave the
second replica inconsistent if we set
this value to one but didn't also set
this value to one
so maybe the rule should be that the
client is always required to talk to
both replicas to both servers for any
operation and shouldn't be allowed to
just talk to one of them so why is that
the wrong answer so the rule is o in our
replicated system the clients always
require to talk to both replicas in
order to make progress at all in fact
it's worse it's worse than talking to a
single server because now the system has
a problem if either of these servers is
crashed or or you can't talk to it at
least with a non replicated service
you're only depending on one server but
here we am both servers have to be a lot
if we require the client to talk to both
servers then both servers has to be live
so we can't possibly require the client
to actually you know wait for both
servers to respond if we don't have
fault tolerance we need it to be able to
proceed so another obvious answer is
that if the client can't talk to both
well it just talks to the one who can
talk to and figures the other ones dead
so what's up why is that also not the
right answer
the troubling scenario is if the other
server is actually alive so suppose the
actual problem or encountering is not
that this server crashed which would be
good for us but the much worse issue
that something went wrong with the
network cable and that this client can
talk to climb one can talk to server one
but not server two and there's maybe
some other client out there that conduct
a server two but not server one so if we
make the rule that if a client can talk
to both servers that it's okay in order
to be fault tolerant that I just talked
to one then what's just inevitably gonna
happen said this cable is gonna break
thus cutting the network in half client
one is gonna send a test and set request
to server one server one will you know
set it state to one and return the
previous value of zero to client one and
so that mean client mom will think it
has the lock and if it's a VMware ft
server will think it can be takeovers
primarily but this replica still of zero
in it all right so now if client to
who've also sends a test and set request
to you know what price to send them to
both sees that server one appears to be
down follows the rule that says well you
just send to the one server but you can
talk to then it will also think that it
would either quiet because client you
also think that it acquired the lock and
so now you know if we were imagining
this test and that server was going to
be used with the and where ft we have
not both replicas both of these VMware
machines I think they could be primary
by themselves without consulting the
other server so that's a complete
failure so with this set up and two
servers it seemed like we had this we
just had to choose either you wait for
both and you're not fault-tolerant or
you wait for just one and you're not
correct and then our correct version
it's often called split brain so
everybody see this well
so this was basically where things stood
until the late 80s and when people but
people did want to build replicated
systems you know like the computers that
control telephone switches or the
computers that ran banks you know there
was placer when we spend a huge amount
of money in order to have reliable
service and so they would replicate they
would build replicated systems and the
way they would deal then way would that
they would have replication but try to
rule out of rule out split brain it's a
couple of techniques one is they would
build a network that could not fail and
so usually what that means and in fact
you guys use networks that essentially
cannot fail all the time the wires
inside your laptop you know connecting
the CPU to the DRAM are effectively what
you know a network that cannot fail
between the between your CPU and DRAM so
you know with reasonable assumptions and
lots of money and you know sort of
carefully controlled physical situation
like you don't want to have a cable
snaking across the floor that somebody
can step on you know it's got to be
physically designed set up with a
network that cannot fail you can rule
out split brain it's bit of an
assumption but with enough money people
get quite close to this because if the
network cannot fail that basically means
that the client can't talk to a server
to that means server two must be down
because it can't have been the network
malfunctioning so that was one way that
people sort of built replication systems
it didn't suffer from split brain
another possibility would be to have
some human beings sort out the problem
that is don't automatically do anything
instead have the clients you know by
default clients always have to wait for
you know both replicas to respond or
something never allowed to proceed with
just one of them but you can you know
call somebody's beeper to go off some
human being goes to the machine room and
sort of looks at the two replicas and
either turns one off to make sure it's
definitely dead
or verifies that one of them has indeed
crashed and if the other is alive and so
you're essentially using the human as a
as the tie breaker and the human is a
you know if they were a computer it
would be a single point if you
themselves so for a long time people use
one of the other these schemes in order
to build replicated systems and it's not
you know they can be made to work the
humans don't respond very quickly and
the network that cannot fail is
expensive but it's not not doable but it
turned out that you can actually build
automated failover systems that can work
correctly in the face of flaky networks
of networks that could fail on the can
partition so this split of the network
in half where the two sides operate they
can't talk to each other that's usually
called a partition and the big insight
that people came up with in order to
build automated replication systems that
don't suffer from split brain is the
idea of a majority vote this is a
concept that shows up in like every
other sentence practically in the raft
paper sort of fundamental way of
proceeding the first step is to have an
odd number of servers instead of an even
number of servers like one flaw here is
that it's a little bit too symmetric all
right the two sides of the split here
just they just look the same so they run
the same software they're gonna do the
same thing and that's not good but if
you have an odd number of servers then
it's not symmetric anymore right at
least a single network split will be
presumably two servers on one side and
one server on the other side and they
won't be symmetric at all and that's
part of what majority vote majority
voting schemes are appealing to so basic
ideas you have an odd number of servers
in order to make progress of any kind so
in raft elect a leader or cause a log
entry to be committed in order to make
any progress at each step you have to
assemble a majority of the server's more
than half more than half of all the
servers in order to sort of approve that
step like vote for a meet or accept a
new log entry and commit it so you know
the most straightforward way is that two
or three servers required to do anything
one reason this works of course is that
if there's a partition there can't be
more than one partition with a majority
of the server's in it that's one way to
look at this a partition can have one
server in it which it's not a majority
or maybe you can have two but if one
partition has two then the other
partition has to have only one server in
it and therefore will never be able to
assemble a majority and won't be able to
make progress and just to be totally
clear when we're talking about a
majority it's always a majority out of
all of the server's not just a live
servers this is the point that confused
me for a long time but if you have a
system with three servers and maybe some
of them have failed or something if you
need to assemble in the majority it's
always two out of three even if you know
that one has failed the majority is
always out of the total number of
servers there's a more general
formulation of this because a majority
voting system in which two out of three
are required to make progress it can
survive the failure of one server right
any two servers are enough to make
progress if you need to be able to if
you're you know you worried about how
reliable your servers are or then you
can build systems that have more servers
and so the more general formulation is
if you have two F + 1 servers then you
can withstand you know so if it's three
that means F is one and the system with
three servers you can tolerate F servers
step one failure and still keep going
all right often these are called quorum
systems because the two out of three is
sometimes held a quorum okay so one
property I've already mentioned about
these majority voting systems is that at
most one partition can have a majority
and therefore if the networks
partitioned we can't have both halves of
the network making progress another more
subtle thing that's going on here is
that if you always need a majority of
the servers to proceed and you go
through a sort of succession of
operations in which reach operations
somebody assembled a majority like you
know votes for leaders or let's say
votes for leaders arrived then at every
step the majority you assemble for that
step must contain at least one server
that was in the previous majority that
is any two majorities overlap in at
least one server and it's really that
property more than anything else that
raft is relying on to avoid split brain
it's the fact that for example when you
have a leader a successful leader
election and leader assembles votes from
a majority its majority is guaranteed to
overlap with the previous leaders
majority and so for example the new
leader is guaranteed to know about the
term number used by the previous leader
because it's a majority overlaps with
the previous leaders majority and
everybody in the previous leaders
majority knew about the previous leaders
term number
similarly anything the previous leader
could have committed must be present in
a majority of the servers in raft and
therefore any new leaders majority must
overlap at at least one server with
every committed entry from the previous
leader this is a big part of why it is
that wrapped is correct
any questions about the general concept
of majority voting systems
these muscle ad servers
it's possible intersection something
maybe six in the paper explains how to
add it or change the set of servers and
it's possible you need to do it in a
long-running system if you're running
your system for five ten years you know
you're gonna need to replace the servers
after a while you know one of them fails
permanently or you upgrade or you move
machine rooms to a different machine
room you really do need to be able to
support changing sets of servers so
that's a it certainly doesn't happen
every day but it's a critical part of
this or a long-term maintainability of
these systems and you know the RAF
authors sort of pat themselves on the
back that they have a scheme that deals
with this which as well they might
because it's complex all right so using
this idea in about 1990 or so there were
two systems proposed at about the same
time that realized that you could use
this majority voting system to kind of
get around the apparent impossibility of
avoiding split brain by using basically
by using three servers instead of two
and taking majority votes and in one of
these very early systems was called
Paxos the RAF paper talks about this a
lot and another of these very early
systems was called view stamp
replication a previa des vs r4 view
stamp replication and even though Paxos
pod is by far the more widely known
system in this department raft is
actually closer to design in design to
view statment few stamp application
which was invented by people at MIT and
so there's a sort of a law many decade
history of these systems and they only
really came to the forefront and started
being used a lot in deployed big
distributed sisty systems about 15 years
ago a good 15 years after they were
originally invented okay so let me talk
about Rath now
raft is a takes the form of a library
intended to be included in some service
application so if you have a replicated
service that each of the replicas in the
service is gonna be some application
code which you know receives rpcs or
something plus a raft library and the
raft libraries cooperate with each other
to mean replication maintain replication
so sort of software overview of a single
raft replica is that at the top we can
think of the replicas having the
application code so it might be for lab
3 a key-value server so maybe we have
some key value server and in a state the
application has state that raft is
helping it manage replicated state and
for a key value server it's going to be
a table of keys and values the next
layer down is a raft layer so the key
value server is gonna sort of make
function calls into raft and they're
gonna chitchat back and forth a little
bit and raft keeps a little bit of state
you can see it in Figure 2 and for our
purposes really the most critical piece
of state is that raft has a log of
operations and a system with 3 breath
will cause we're actually gonna have you
know 3 servers that have exactly the
same identical structure and hopefully
the very same data sitting in sitting at
both layers
right outside of this there's gonna be
clients and the game is that so we have
you know client 1 and client two whole
bunch of clients the clients don't
really know the clients are you know
just external code that needs to be able
to use the service and the hope is the
clients won't really need to be aware
that they're talking to a replicated
service that to the clients that are
looking almost like it's just one server
and they talked with one server and so
the clients actually send client
requests to the key to the application
layer of the current leader the replica
that's the current leader in raft and so
these are gonna be you know application
level requests for a database for a key
value server these might be put in get
requests you know put takes a key and a
value and updates the table and get
asked the service to get the current key
current value corresponding to some key
so this like has nothing about to do
with raft it's just sort of
client-server interaction for whatever
service we're building but once one of
these commands gets sent from the
requests get sent from the clients of
the server what actually happens is you
know on a non replicated server the
application code would like execute this
request and say update the table and
response to a book but not in a raft
replicated service instead if assuming
the client sends a request to leader
what really happens is the application
layer simply sends the request the
clients request down into the raft layer
to say look you know here's a request
please get it committed into the
replicated log and tell me when you're
done and so at this point the rafts
chitchat with each other until all the
replicas are a majority the replicas get
this new operation into their logs said
it is replicated and then when its
leader knows that all of the replicas of
a copy of this only then as a raft sent
a notification up back up to the key
value they are saying aha that operation
you sent me I mean
it's been now committed into all the
replicas and so it's safely replicated
and at this point it's okay to execute
that operation a raft you know the
client sends a request with the key
value layer Q value layer does not
execute it yet so we're not sure because
it hasn't been replicated only when it's
in out and the logs of all the replicas
then raft notifies the leader now the
leader actually execute the operation
which corresponds to you know for a put
updating the value yet reading correct
value out of the table and then finally
sends the reply back to the client so
that's the ordinary operation of it
submitted if it's in a majority and
again the reason why I can't be all is
that if we want to build a
fault-tolerant system it has to be able
to make progress even if some of the
server's have failed so yeah so ever
it's committed when it's in a majority
[Music]
yeah and so in addition when operations
finally committed each of the replicas
sends the operation up each of the raft
library layer sends the operation up to
the local application layer in the local
application layer applies that operation
to its state its state and so they all
so hopefully all the replicas seem the
same stream of operations they show up
in these up calls in the same order they
get applied to the state in the same
order and you know assuming the
operations are deterministic which they
better be the state of the replicas
replicated State will evolve in
identically on all the replicas so
typically this this table is what the
paper is talking about when it talks
about state a different way of viewing
this interaction and one that'll sort of
notation that will come up a lot in this
course is that a sort of time diagram
I'll draw you a time diagram of how the
messages work so let's imagine we have a
client and server one is the leader that
we also have server to server three and
time flows downward on this diagram we
imagine the client sending the original
request to server one after that server
ones raft layer sends an append entries
RPC to each of the two replicas this is
just an ordinary I'll say a put request
this is append entries requests the
server is now waiting for replies and
the server's from other replicas as soon
as replies from a majority arrive back
including the leader itself so in a
system with only three about because the
leader only has to wait for one other
replica to respond positively to an
append entries as soon as it assembles
positive responses from a majority the
leader
execute a command figures out what the
answer is like forget
and sends the reply back to the client
I mean why of course you know if s who's
actually awry alive it'll send back its
response too but we're not waiting for
it although it's useful to know and
figure - all right everybody see this
this is the sort of ordinary operation
of the system no no failures
oh gosh yeah I like I left out important
steps so you know this point the leader
knows oh I got you know I'm adora t have
put it in no log I can go ahead and
execute it and reply yes to the client
because it's committed but server two
doesn't know anything yet it just knows
well you know I got this request from
the leader but I don't know if it's
committed yet depends on for example
whether my reply got back to the leader
for all server to knows it's reply was
brought by the network maybe the leader
never heard the reply and never decided
to commit this request so there's
actually another stage once the server
realizes that a request is committed it
then needs to tell the other replicas
that fact and so there are there's
there's an extra message here exactly
what that message is depends a little
bit on what what else is going on it's
at least in raft there's not an explicit
commit message instead the information
is piggybacked inside the next append
entries that leader sends out the next
append entries RPC it sends out for
whatever reason like there's a commit
meter commit or something filled in that
RPC and the next time the leader needs
have to send a heartbeat heartbeat or
needs to send out a new client request
because some different client requests
or something it'll send out the new hire
leader commit value and at that point
the replicas will execute the operation
and apply it to their state yes
oh yes so this is a this is a protocol
that has a quite a bit of chitchat in it
and it's not super fast indeed you know
yeah client sends in request request has
to get to the server the server talks to
at least you know another instance that
multiple messages has to wait for the
responses send something back so there's
a bunch of message round-trip times kind
of embedded here
yes if so this is up to you as the
implementer actually exactly when the
leader sends out the updated commit
index if client requests a comeback only
very occasionally then you know the
leader may want to send out a heartbeat
or send out a special append entries
message if client requests come quite
frequently then it doesn't matter
because if they come you know there's
thousand arrive per second and gee so
it'll be another one along very soon and
so you can piggyback so without
generating an extra message which is
somewhat expensive you can get the
information out on the next message you
were gonna send anyway in fact I I don't
think the time at which the replicas
execute the request is critical because
nobody's waiting for it at least if
there's no failures if there's no
failures replicas executing the request
isn't really on the critical path like
the client isn't waiting for them the
client saw me waiting for the leader to
execute so it may not be that it may not
affect client perceived latency sort of
exactly how this gets staged
all right one question you should ask is
why does the system why is the system so
focused on blogs what are the logs doing
and it's sort of worth trying to come up
with an explicit answers to that one
answer to why the system is totally
focused on logs is that the log is the
kind of mechanism by which the leader
orders operations it's vital for these
replicated state machines that all the
replicas apply not just the same client
operations to their start but the same
operations in the same order but they
all have to apply that these operations
coming from the clients in the same
order and the log among many other
things is part of the machinery by which
the or the leader assigns an order to
the incoming client operations I give
you know ten clients send operations to
the leader at the same time the client
the leader has to pick pick an order
make sure everybody all the replicas
obey that order and the log is you know
the fact that the log has numbered slots
as part of half a meter expresses the
order it's chosen another use of the log
is that between this point and this
point server 3 has received an operation
that it is not yet sure is committed and
it cannot execute it yet it has to put
the this operation aside somewhere until
the increment to the leader commit value
comes in and so another thing that the
log is doing is that on the followers
the log is the place where the follower
sort of sets aside operations that are
still tentative that have arrived but
are not yet known to be committed and
they may have to be thrown away as we'll
see so that's another use I'm the I sort
of do love that use on the leader side
is that the leader needs to remember
operations in its log because it may
need to retransmit them to followers if
some followers offline maybe it's
something briefly happened to its
network
action or something misses some messages
the leader needs to be able to resend
log messages that any followers missed
and so the leader needs a place where
can set aside copies of messages of
client requests even ones that it's
already executed in order to be able to
resend them to the client I mean we send
them to replicas that missed missed that
operation and a final reason for all of
them to keep the log is that at least in
the world of figure 2 if a server
crashes and restarts and wants to rejoin
and you really need if it you really
want a server that crashes - in fact we
start and rejoin the raft cluster
otherwise you're now operating with only
two out of three servers and you can't
survive any more failures we need to
reincorporate failed and rebooted
servers and the log is sort of where or
what a server rebooted server uses the
log persisted to its disk because one of
the rules is that each raft server needs
to write its log to its disk where it
will still be after it crashes and
restarts that log is what the server
uses or replays the operations in that
log from the beginning to sort of create
its state as of when it crashed and then
then it carries on from there so the log
is also used as part of the persistence
plan as a sequence of commands to
rebuild the state
well ultimately okay so the question is
suppose the leader is capable of
executing a thousand client commands a
second and the followers are only
incapable of executing a hundred client
commands per second that's sort of
sustained rate you know full speed v so
one thing to note is that the the
replicas the followers acknowledge
commands before they execute them so
they mate rate at which they acknowledge
and accumulate stuff in their logs is
not limited so you know maybe they can
acknowledge that a thousand requests per
second if they do that forever then they
will build up unbounded size logs
because their execution rate falls it
will fall on an unbounded amount behind
the rate at which the leader has given
the messages sort of under the rules of
our game and so what that means they
will eventually run out of memory at
some point so after they have a billion
after they fall a billion log entries
behind those just like they'll call the
memory allocator for space for a new
blog entry and it will fail so yeah and
Raph doesn't Raph doesn't have the flow
controls that's required to cope with
this so I think in a real system you
would actually need you know probably
piggybacked and doesn't need to be
real-time but you probably need some
kind of additional communication here
that says well here's how far I've
gotten in execution so that the leader
can say well you know too many thousands
of requests ahead of the point in which
the followers have executed yes I think
there's probably you know in a
production system that you're trying to
push to the absolute max you would you
might well need an extra message to
throttle the leader if it got too far
ahead
okay so the question is if if one of
these servers crashes it has this log
that it persisted to disk because that's
one of the rules of figure two so the
server will be able to be just logged
back from disk but of course that server
doesn't know how far it got in executing
the log and also it doesn't know at
least when it first reboots by the rule
that figure two it doesn't even know how
much of the log is committed so the
first answer to your question is that
immediately after a restart you know
after a server crashes and restarts and
reads its log it is not allowed to do
anything with the log because it does
not know how far the system has
committed in its log maybe as long as
has a thousand uncommitted entries and
zero committed entries for all it notes
so
it's a leader dye support that doesn't
help either but let's suppose they've
all crashed this is getting ahead of its
getting a bit ahead of me but well
suppose they've all crashed and so all
they have is the state that was marked
as non-volatile in figure 2 which
includes the log and maybe the latest
term and so they don't know some if
there's a crash but they all crash and
they always start none of them knows
initially how far they had been have
executed before the crash so what
happens is that you leader election one
of them gets picked as a leader and that
leader if you sort of track through what
figure 2 says about how a pendant Rees
is supposed to work the leader will
actually figure out as a byproduct of
sending out a pendant or sending out the
first heartbeat really it'll fake it'll
figure out what the latest point is
basically that that all of the that a
majority of the replicas agree on their
laws because that's the commit point
another way of looking at it is that
once you choose a leader through the
append entries mechanism the leader
forces all of the other replicas to have
identical logs to the leader and at that
point plus a little bit of extra the
paper explains at that point since the
leader knows that it's forced all the
replicas to have it I didn't have logs
that are identicals to it then it knows
that all the replicas must also have a
there must be a majority of replicas
with that all those log injuries in that
logs which are now are identical must
also be committed because they're held
on a majority of replicas and at that
point a leader you know the append
entries code described in Figure 2 for
the leader will increment the leaders
commit point and everybody can now
execute the entire log from the
beginning and recreate their state from
scratch possibly extremely laborious Lee
so that's what figure two says it's
obviously this be executing from scratch
is not very attractive but it's where
the basic protocol does and we'll see
tomorrow that the the sort of version of
this is more efficient to use as
checkpoints and we'll talk about
tomorrow okay so this was a sequence in
sort of ordinary non failure operation
another thing I want to briefly mention
is what this interface looks like you've
probably all seen a little bit of it due
to working on the labs but roughly
speaking if you have let's say that this
key value layer with its state and the
raft layer underneath it there's on each
replica there's really two main pieces
of the interface between them there's
this method by which the key value layer
can relay if a client sends in a request
the key value layer has to give it to
wrap and say please you know fit this
request into the log somewhere and
that's the start function that you'll
see in Raph go and really just takes one
argument the client command the key
value they're saying please I got this
command to get into the log and tell me
when it's committed and the other piece
of the interface is that by and by the
raft layer will notify the key value
layer that AHA that operation that you
sent to me in a start command a while
ago which may well not be the most
recent start right there you know a
hundred client commands could come in
and cause calls to start before any of
them are committed so by and by this
upward communication is takes the form
of a message on a go channel that the
raft library sends on and key value
layer is supposed to read from so
there's this apply called the apply
channel and on it on it you send apply
message
this start and of course you need the
the key value layer needs to be able to
match up message that receives an apply
channel with calls to start that it made
and so the start command actually
returns enough information for that
matchup to happen it returns the index
that start functions basically returns
the index in the log where if this
command is committed which it might not
be it'll be committed at this index and
I think it also returns the current term
and some other stuff we don't care about
very much and then this apply message is
going to contain the index command and
all the replicas will get these apply
messages so they'll all know though I
should apply this command figure out
what this command means and apply it to
my local State and they also get the
index the index is really only useful
I'm the leader so it can figure out what
client would what client requests were
talking about
by
the answer a slightly different question
let's suppose the client sends any
request in let's say it's a put or a get
could be put or again it doesn't really
matter I'd say it to get the point in
which the it's a client sense and again
and waits for a response the point at
which the leader will send a response at
all is after the leader knows that
command is committed so this is going to
be a sort of get reply so the client
doesn't see anything back I mean and so
that means in terms of the actual
software stack that means that the key
value the RPC will arrive the key value
layer will call the start function the
start function will return to the key
value layer but the key value layer will
not yet reply to the client because it
does not know if it's good actually it
hasn't executed the clients request now
it doesn't even know if it ever will
because it's not sure if the request is
going to be committed right in the
situation which may not be committed is
if the key value layer you know guess
the request calls start and immediately
after starboard turn two crashes right
certainly hasn't sent out its apply what
append messages or whatever
nothing's be committed yep so so the
game is start returns time passes the
relevant apply message corresponding to
that client request appears to the key
value server on the apply channel and
only then and that causes the key value
server to execute the request and send
her a plot
and that's like all this is very
important when it doesn't really matter
if all everything goes well but if
there's a failure we're now at the point
where we start worrying about theatres I
mean extremely interested in if there
was a failure what did the client see
all right and so one thing that does
come up is that all of you should be
familiar with this that at least
initially one interesting thing about
the logs is that they may not be
identical there are a whole bunch of
situations in which at least for brief
periods of time the ends of the
different replicas logs may diverge like
for example if a leader starts to send
out a round of append messages but
crashes before it's able to send all
them out you know that'll mean that some
of the replicas that got the append
message will append you know that new
log entry and the ones that didn't get
that append messages RPC won't have
appended them so it's easy to see that
the logs are I'm gonna diverge sometimes
the good news is that the the way a raft
works actually ends up forcing the logs
to be identical after a while there may
be transient differences but in the long
run all the logs will sort of be
modified by the leader until the leader
insurers are all identical and only then
are they executed okay so I think the
next there's really two big topics to
talk about here for raft one is how
leader election works which is lab two
and the other is how the leader deals
with the different replicas logs
particularly after failure so first I
want to talk about leader election
question to ask is how come the system
even has a leader why do we need a
leader the part of the answer is you do
not need a leader to build a system like
this you it is possible to build an
agreement system by which a cluster of
servers agrees you know the sequence of
entries in a log without having any kind
of designated leader
and indeed the original pack so system
which the paper refers to original Paxos
did not have a leader so it's possible
the reason why raft has a leader is
basically that there's probably a lot of
reasons but one of the foremost reasons
is that you can build a more efficient
in the common case in which the server's
don't fail it's possible to build a more
efficient system if you have a leader
because with a designated leader
everybody knows who the leader is you
can basically get agreement on requests
that with one round of messages per
request where as leader of this systems
have more of the flavor of well you need
a first round to kind of agree on a
temporary leader and then a second round
actually send out the requests so it's
probably the case that use of a leader
now speeds up the system by a factor two
and it also makes it sort of easier to
think about what's going on raft goes
through a sequence of leaders and it
uses these term numbers in order to sort
of disambiguate which leader we're
talking about it turns out that
followers don't really need to know the
identity of the leader they really just
need to know what the current term
number is each term has at most one
leader that's a critical property you
know for every term there might be no
leader during that term or there might
be one leader but there cannot be two
leaders during the same term every term
has it must most one leader how do the
leaders get created in the first place
every raft server keeps this election
timer which is just a it's basically
just out of time that it has recorded
that says well if that time occurs I'm
going to do something and the something
that it does is that if an entire leader
election period expires without the
server having heard any message from the
current leader then the server sort of
assumes probably that the current leader
is dead and starts an election so we
have this election timer
and if it expires we start an election
and what it means to start an election
is basically that you increment the term
the the candidate the server that's
decided it's going to be a candidate and
sort of force a new election first
increments this term because it wants
them to be a new leader namely itself
and you know leader a term can't have
more than one leader so we got to start
a new term in order to have a new leader
and then it sends out these requests
boats are pea seeds I'm going to send
out a full round of request votes and
you may only have to send out n minus
one requests votes because one of the
rules is that a new candidate always
votes for itself in the election so one
thing to note about this is that it's
not quite the case that if the leader
didn't fail we won't have an election
but if the leader does fail then we will
have election an election assuming any
other server is up because some day the
other servers election timers go will go
off but as leader didn't fail we might
still unfortunately get an election so
if the network is slow or drops a few
heartbeats or something we may end up
having election timers go off and even
though there was a perfectly good leader
we may nevertheless have a new election
so we have to sort of keep that in mind
when we're thinking about the
correctness and what that in turn means
is that if there's a new election it
could easily be the case that the old
leader is still hanging around and still
thinks it's the leader like if there's a
network partition for example and the
old leader is still alive and well in a
minority partition the majority
partition may run an election and indeed
a successful election and choose a new
leader all totally unknown to the
previous leader so we also have to worry
about you know what's that previous
leader gonna do since it does not know
there was a new election yes
okay so the question is are there can
there be pathological cases in which for
example one-way network communication
can prevent the system from making
progress I believe the answer is yes
certainly so for example if the current
leader if its network somehow half fails
in a way the current leader can send out
heartbeats
but can't receive any client requests
then the heartbeats that it sends out
which are delivered because it's
outgoing network connection works its
outgoing heartbeats will suppress any
other server from starting an election
but the fact that it's incoming Network
why or apparently is broken will prevent
it from hearing and executing any client
commands it's absolutely the case that
raft is not proof against all sort of
all crazy Network problems that can come
up I believe the ones I've thought about
I believe are fixable in the sense that
the we could solve this one by having a
sort of requiring a two-way heartbeat in
which if the leader sends out heartbeats
but you know there were in which
followers are required to reply in some
way to heartbeats I guess they are
already required to apply if the leader
stop seeing replies to its heartbeats
then after some amount of time and which
is seasonals replies the leader decides
to step down I feel like that specific
issue can be fixed and many others can
too but I but you know you're absolutely
right that very strange things can
happen to networks including some that
the protocol is not prepared for
okay so we got these meter elections we
need to ensure that there is at most at
most one meter per term
how does Rath do that well Rath requires
in order to be elected for a term Raft
requires a candidate to get yes votes
from a majority of the server's the
servers and each server will only cast
one yes vote per term so in any given
term you know it basically means that in
any given term Easter votes only once
for only one candidate you can't have
two candidates both get a majority of
votes because everybody votes only once
so the majorities majority rule causes
there to be at most one winning
candidate and so then we get at most one
candidate elected per turn
and in addition critically the majority
rule means that you can get elected even
if some servers have crashed right if a
minority of servers are crashed aren't
available and network problems we can
still elect a leader if more than half a
crash or not available or in another
partition or something then actually the
system will just sit there trying again
and again to elect a leader and never
elect one if it cannot in fact they're
not a majority of live servers if an
election succeeds everybody would be
great if everybody learned about it I
mean need to ask ourselves how do all
the parties learn learn what happened
the server that wins an election
assuming it doesn't crash the server
that wins election will actually see a
majority or positive votes for its
request vote from a majority of the
other servers so the candidates running
the election that wins it the Kennedy
that wins the election will actually
know directly uh I got a majority of
votes but nobody else directly knows who
the winner was or whether anybody one so
the way that the candidate informs other
servers is that heartbeat the rules and
figure to say oh if you're in an
election your immediately required to
send out an independent
trees to all the other servers now the
append entries that heartbeat append
entries doesn't explicitly say I won the
election you know I'm a leader for term
23 it's a little more subtle than that
the the way the information is
communicated is that no one is allowed
to send out an append entries unless
they're a leader for that term so the
fact that I I'm a you know I'm a server
and I saw oh there's an election for
term 19 and then by-and-by I sent an
append entries whose term is 19 that
tells me that somebody I don't know who
but somebody won the election so that's
how the other servers knows they were
receiving append entries for that term
and that append entries also has the
effect of resetting everybody's election
time timer so as long as the leader is
up and it sends out heartbeat messages
or append entries at least you know at
the rate that's supposed to every time a
server receives an append entries it'll
reset its selection timer and sort of
suppress anybody from being a new
candidate so as long as everything's
functioning the repeated heartbeats will
prevent any further elections of course
it the network fails or packets are
dropped there may nevertheless be an
election but if all goes well we're sort
of unlikely to get an election this
scheme could fail in the sense that it
can't fail in the sense of electing to
leaders fair term but it can fail in the
sense of electing zero leaders for a
term that's sort of morningway it may
fail is that if too many servers are
dead or unavailable or a bad network
connection so if you can't assemble a
majority you can't be elected nothing
happens the more interesting way in
which an election can fail is if
everybody's up you know there's no
failures no packets are dropped but two
leaders become candidate close together
enough in time that they split the vote
between them or say three leaders
so supposing we have three liters
supposing we have a three replica system
all their election timers go off at the
same time every server both for itself
and then when each of them receives a
request vote from another server well
it's already cast its vote for itself
and so it says no so that means that it
all three of the server's needs to get
one vote each nobody gets a majority and
nobody's elected so then their election
timers will go off again because the
election timers only be said if it gets
an append entries but there's no leader
so no append entries they'll all have
their election timers go off again and
if we're unlucky
they'll all go off at the same time
they'll all go for themselves nobody
will get a majority so so clearly I'm
sure you're all aware at this point
there's more to this story and the way
Raft makes this possibility of split
votes unlikely but not impossible
is by randomizing these election timers
so the way to think of it and the
randomization the way to think of it is
that supposing you have some time line
I'm gonna draw a vents on there's some
point at which everybody received the
last append entries right and then maybe
the server died let's just assume the
server send out a last heartbeat and
then died well all of the followers have
this we set their election timers when
they received at the same time because
they probably all receive this append
enters at the same time they all reset
their election timers for some point in
the future the future but they chose
different random times in the future
which then we're gonna go off
so it's suppose the dead leader server
one so now server two and server 3 at
this point set their election timers for
a random point in the future let's say
server to set their I like some timer to
go off here and server 3 set its
election timer to go off there and the
crucial point about this picture is that
assuming they picked different random
numbers one of them is first and the
other one is second right that's what's
going on here and the one that's first
assuming
this gap is big enough the one that's
first it's election time will go off
first before the other ones election
timer and if we're close were not
unlucky
it'll have time to send out a full round
of vote requests and get answers from
everybody who everybody's alive before
the second election timer goes off from
any other server so does everybody see
how the randomization D synchronizes
these candidates unfortunately there's a
bit of art in setting the contents
constants for these election timers
there's some sort of competing
requirements you might want to fulfill
so one obvious requirement is that the
election timer has to be at least as
long as the expected interval between
heartbeats
you know this is pretty obvious that the
leader sends out heartbeats every
hundred milliseconds you better make
sure there's no point in having the
election time or anybody's election time
or ever go off Borja for 100
milliseconds because then it will go off
before the lower limit is certainly the
lower limit is one heartbeat interval in
fact because the network may drop
packets you probably want to have the
minimum election timer value be a couple
of times the heartbeat interval so 400
millisecond heartbeats you probably want
to have the very shortest possible
election time or be you know say 300
milliseconds you know three times the
heartbeat interval so that's the sort of
minimum is the heart heartbeat so this
frequent you want the minimum to be you
know a couple of times that or here so
what about the maximum you know you're
gonna presumably randomize uniformly
over some range of times you know where
should we set the kind of maximum time
that we're randomizing over there's a
couple of considerations here in a real
system you know this maximum time effect
how quickly the system can recover from
failure because remember from the time
at which the server fails until the
first election timer goes off the whole
system is frozen there's no leader you
know the clients requests are being
thrown away because there's no leader
and we're not assigning a new leader
even though you know presumably these
other servers are up so the beer we
choose this maximum the long or delay
we're imposing on clients before
recovery occurs you know whether that's
important depends on sort of how high
performance we need this to be and how
often we think there will be failures
failures happen once a year then who
cares
we're expecting failures frequently we
may care very much how long it takes to
recover okay so that's one consideration
the other consideration is that this gap
that is the expected gap in time between
the first time are going off and the
second timer going off this gap really
in order to be useful has to be longer
than the time it takes for the candidate
to assemble votes from everybody that is
longer than the expected round-trip time
the amount of time it takes to send an
RPC and get the response and so maybe it
takes 10 milliseconds to send an RPC and
get a response a response from all the
other servers and if that's the case we
need to make maximum at least long
enough that there's pretty likely to be
10 milliseconds difference between the
smallest random number and the next
smallest random number
and for you the test code will get upset
if you if you don't recover from a
leader failure in a couple seconds and
so just pragmatically you need to tune
this maximum down so that it's highly
likely that you'll be able to complete a
leader election within a few seconds but
that's not a very tight constraint any
questions about the election time outs
one tiny point is that you want to
choose new random time outs every time
there's every time you every time I node
sets it to like me sets its election
timer that is don't choose a random
number when the server is first created
and then we use that same number over
and over again because you make an
unlucky choice that is you choose this
one server happens by ill chance to
choose the same random number as another
server that means that you're gonna have
split votes over and over again forever
that's why you want to almost certainly
choose a different a new fresh random
number for the election time out value
every time you reset the timer all right
so the final issue about leader election
suppose we are in this situation where
the old leaders partition you know the
network cable is broken and the old
leader is sort of out there with a
couple clients and a minority of servers
and there's a majority in the other half
of the network and the majority of the
new half of the network elects a new
leader what about the old leader why why
won't the old leader cause incorrect
execution
yes to two potential problems one is or
one some non problem is that if there's
a leader off in another partition and it
doesn't have a majority then the next
time a client sends it a request that
that leader that you know in a partition
with a minority yeah it'll send out
append entries but because it's in the
minority partition it won't be able to
get responses back from a majority of
the server's including itself and so it
will never commit the operation it will
never execute it
it'll never respond to the client saying
that it executed it either and so that
means that yeah an old server often a
different partition people many clients
may send a request but they'll never get
responses so no client will be fooled
into thinking that that old server
executed anything for it the other sort
of more tricky issue which actually I'll
talk about in a few minutes is the
possibility that before server fails it
sends out append entries to a subset of
the servers and then crashes before
making a commission and as a very
interesting question which I'll probably
spend a good 45 minutes talking about
and so actually before I turn to the
back topic in general any more questions
about in leader election okay
okay so how about the contents of the
logs and how in particular how a newly
elected leader possibly picking up the
pieces after an awkward crash of the
previous leader how does a newly elected
leader sort out the possibly divergent
logs on the different replicas in order
to restore sort of consistent state in
the system all right so the first
question is what can think this is this
whole topic it's really only interesting
after a server crashes right if the
server stays up then relatively few
things can go wrong if we have a server
that's up and has a majority you know
during the period of time when it's up
and has a majority it just tells the
followers what the logs should look like
and the followers are not allowed to
disagree they're required to accept they
just do by the rules of figure two if
they've been more or less keeping up you
know they just take whatever the leader
sends them independent reason appended
to the log and obey commit messages and
execute there's hardly anything to go
wrong the things that go wrong in Rapp
go wrong when a the old leader crashes
sort of midway through you know sending
out messages or a new leader crashes you
know sort of just after it's been
elected but before it's done anything
very useful so one thing we're very
interested in is what can the logs look
like after some sequence of crashes okay
so here's an example supposing we have
two servers and the way I'm gonna draw
out these diagrams because we're gonna
be looking a lot at a lot of sort of
situations where the logs look like this
and we're gonna be wondering is that
possible and what happens if they do
look like that so my notation is going
to be I'm gonna write out log entries
for each of the servers sort of aligned
to indicate slots corresponding slots in
the log and the values I'm going to
write here are the term numbers rather
than
client operations I'm going to you know
this is slot one this is thought to
everybody saw a command from term three
in slot 1 and server tuned server three
saw command from also term three and the
second slot the server one has nothing
there at all and so question for this
like the very first question is can this
arrive could this setup arise and how
yes
so you know maybe server 3 was the
leader for just repeating what you said
maybe server 3 is the leader for term 3
he got a command that sent out to
everybody everybody received a dependent
at the log and then I got a server 3 got
a second request from a client and maybe
it sent it to all three servers but the
message got lost on the way to server
one or maybe server was down at the time
or something and so only server to the
leader always append new commands to its
log before it sends out append entries
and maybe the append entry RPC only got
to server 2 so this situation you know
it's like the simplest situation and was
actually the logs are not different and
we know how it could possibly arise and
so if server 3 which is a leadership
crash now you know the next server
they're gonna need to make sure server 1
well first of all if server 3 crashes or
we'll be at an election and some of the
leader is chosen you know two things
have to happen the new leader has got to
recognize that this command could have
committed it's not allowed to throw it
away
and it needs to make sure server one
fills in this blank here with indeed
this very same command that everybody
else had in that slot all right so after
a crash somebody you know server 3
suppose another way this can come up is
server 3 might have sent out the append
entries the server 2 but then crashed
before sending the append entries to
server 3 so if were you know electing a
new leader it could because we got a
crash before the message was sent
here's another scenario to think about
three servers again no I mean a number
the slots in the law and so we can refer
to them got slot 10 11 12 13
[Music]
again it's same setup except now we have
in slide 12 we have server 2 as a
command from term for and server 3 has a
term command from term 5
so you know before we analyze these to
figure out what would happen and what
would a server do if it saw this we need
to ask could this even occur because
sometimes the answer to the question oh
jeez what would happen if this
configuration arose sometimes the answer
is it cannot arise so we do not have to
worry about it the question is could
this arise and how
all right so any
[Music]
yeah
in brief we know this configuration can
arise and so the way we can then get the
four and a five here is let's suppose in
the next leader election server twos
elected leader now for term for its
elected leader because a request from a
client it appends it to its own log and
crashes so now we have this right we
need a new election because the leader
just crashed now in this election and
then so now we have to ask whether who
could be elected or we have to give him
back of our heads oh gosh what could be
elected so we're gonna claim server
three could be elected the reason why I
could be elected is because it only
needs request vote responses from
majority that majority is server one and
server three you know there's no no
problem no conflict between these two
logs so server three can be elected for
term five get a request from a client
append it to its own log and crash and
that's how you get this this
configuration so you know you need to be
able to to work through these things in
order to get to the stage of saying yes
this could happen and therefore raft
must do something sensible as opposed to
it cannot happen because some things
can't happen
all right so so what can happen now we
know this can occur so hopefully we can
convince ourselves that raft actually
does something sensible now as for the
range of things before we talk about
what RAF would actually would actually
do we need to have some sense of what
would be an acceptable outcome right and
just eyeballing this we know that the
command in slot 10 since it's known by
all all the replicas it could have been
committed so we cannot throw it away
similarly the command in slot 11 since
it's in a majority of the replicas it
could for all we know have been
committed so we can't throw it away the
command in slot 12 however neither of
them could possibly have been committed
so we're entitled we don't know haven't
we'll actually do but raft is entitled
to drop both of these even though it is
not entitled to drop it and either of
the commands in a 10 or 11
this is entitled dropped it's not
required to drop either one of them but
I mean oh it certainly must drop one at
least one because you have to have
identical log contents in the end
this could have been committed it the we
can't tell by looking at the laws
exactly how far the leader got before
crashing so one possibility is that for
this command or even this command one
possibility is that leaders send out the
append messages with a new command and
then immediately crashed so it never got
any response back because it crashed so
the old leader did not know if it was
committed and if it didn't get a
response back that means it didn't
execute it and it didn't send out but
you know it didn't send out that
incremented commit index and so maybe
the replicas didn't execute it either so
it's actually possible that this wasn't
committed so even though RAF doesn't
know it could be legal for raft
if raft knew more than it does know it
might be legal to drop this log entry
because it might not have been committed
but because on the evidence there's no
way to disprove it was committed based
on this evidence it could have been
committed and raft can't prove it wasn't
so it must treat it as committed because
the leader might have received it might
have crashed just after receiving the
append entry replies and replying to the
client so just looking at this we can't
rule out the possibility that either
possibility that the leader responded to
the client in which case we cannot throw
away this entry because a client knows
about it or the possibility the leader
never did and yeah we could you know if
we have to assume that it was committed
yeah
no there's no maana server crash before
getting the response it's alright well
let's continue this on Thursday